-And I now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
"worst first date" stories
from you guys.
This first one's from
@jordancohen2u.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-[ Sniffs ]
-This one's from
@annabanana0626.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"It's a Mercedes Benz.
I kind of like it."
-Yeah.
-"Whose car is this?"
-I'll wait.
-This one's from
@foreversmiling2.
She says...
[ Cheers and applause ]
"13 rolls of sushi."
"Well, whatever you say.
Bring 'em -- keep bringing 'em."
"I've been here before."
This one's from @snookicookie16.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Puppy trumpet.
-Puppy trumpet.
Ugh.
What a garbage person.
-[ Laughs ]
-It's my puppy trumpet, man.
-It said the end of the night --
at the end of the date,
it was the ol' puppy trumpet.
-Ol' puppy trumpet.
This one's from @Hotovy.
Hotovy?
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Never gonna win.
-They're married!
-You're never gonna win, dude.
He's married.
-He learned his lesson early.
-Exactly, yeah.
This one's from @PatrickAH81.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I'm clean.
-It's not pee.
-Yeah, not pee.
-All right, well, what is it?
-It's a little bit of poop.
[ Laughter ]
-This one's from
@lindachilders1.
She said...
-Oh!
-What!
I know you! That's fate!
-That's fate!
-Oh, my goodness.
This one's from @Mfonda.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-He could have used
the puppy trumpet.
[ Laughter ]
-That's what you use it for,
man.
-Yeah, that's what you got to
get there.
-That's what you use it for,
yeah.
Next one is from
our very own Questlove.
-Oh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This is very interesting here.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
That was it? That was it?
That was it.
-There's only 280 characters.
I couldn't go on.
-Yeah, yeah. Have you ever tried
to go on a second date, or no?
-I didn't get a second date, no.
[ Laughter ]
-Rosario -- we got to bring this
up when she comes on.
[ Laughter ]
That's the greatest --
Tariq, you have
a worst first date story?
-No, all my first dates,
they went swimmingly.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Swimmingly -- swimmingly.
-Last one here is from @ash10g.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
There you have it.
Those are our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.